deux raisons de problématiques la
première évidemment une problématique
salaire nous avons 8 ans de blocage des
salaires suite à la grève en juillet
nous avons eu 1,4% d'augmentation de
salaire qui est ridicule au regard des
huit années de blocage et au regard de
l'inflation que l'INSEE nous avons plus
de 10 % pour pour cette année la SNCF
une entreprise qui a fait plus de 2
milliards d'euros de bénéfices et la
deuxième raison c'est les froids les
mois qui a déclenché chez les cheminots
et chez les milliers de salariés en
France le recours réquisition de la part
du gouvernement c'est-à-dire une réponse
uniquement policière à la grève beaucoup
de brutalité la réquisition c'est pas
juste un acte administratif c'est des
policiers des gendarmes qui viennent
chez vous éventuellement vous menottes
devant vos familles pour vous faire
tourner au travail
[Musique]
alors c'est extrêmement suivi notamment
à la conduite mais aussi chez les
aiguilleurs et on a déjà les annonces de
perturbation pour mardi
donc pour demain c'est plus de 50% des
circulations qui sont supprimées sur la
ligne C qui est la ligne sur laquelle je
conduis et aussi sur les lignes un qui
sont représentés dans les Yvelines donc
c'est un mouvement qui est large qui est
fort et qui s'est organisé à l'arrache
en quelques heures en quelques jours
donc qui montre que vraiment il y a un
émoi très important des cheminots sur la
question des salaires et bien sûr sur la
question de la défense du droit de grève
la Fédération CGT des cheminots et ses
syndicats CGT en local ont mis à
disposition des cheminots des préavis
pouvant être reconduits de façon à ce
que les cheminots décident par eux-mêmes
en assemblée générale mais je peux vous
annoncer déjà que la direction annonce
déjà sur ma ligne la ligne C un S3
c'est-à-dire un service de grève avec
seulement deux trains sur trois en
circulation pour le mercredi alors même
que la grève de demain n'a pas commencé
et que les assemblées générales n'ont
pas eu lieu donc il n'est absolument pas
exclure que le mouvement se continue si
la direction de la SNCF ne fait pas un
pas vers les cheminots pour négocier sur
la base des revendications sur les
augmentations de salaires
[Musique]